so there are lots of biases that you can
basically count on your perceiver being
subject to their going to interfere with
the way this person sees you I'm the
first and probably most common is the
confirmation bias so confirmation bias
is the brains tendency to once you start
to kind of go get a sense of what
someone is like so you show in an
initial interaction you start to feel
like this is a funny person or this is a
smart person or this is someone I can
trust and once you start to have that
initial hunch your brain naturally looks
for information that confirms that
initial hunch and kind of ignores
everything else psychologists also refer
to this tendency to really latch on to
early information about a person as the
primacy effect and basically what that
means is the information we learn first
about another person disproportionately
shapes our understanding of them
afterward and so you know in a way I
sometimes feel bad talking about that
because I'd love to be the person that
came and said you know how everyone
tells you that first impressions are so
important don't worry about it they're
not that important if anything what the
science shows is that they're really
more important than you even think they
are because that first impression is
those those initial information that
person other person gets about you will
have a really major effect on everything
else they see so for example if in your
initial encounter with someone you come
across as kind of a jerk and they you
know it you realize afterwards that you
didn't come across the way you intended
to and so the next day when you come in
to work let's say you bring them a cup
of coffee and you think well that'll be
nice too nice gesture it'll show them
that I'm not a jerk it's actually more
likely to happen is that they're going
to interpret the you giving them coffee
in with the lens of the understanding of
how you were a jerk before so they'll
say oh can you believe this jerk who's
trying to manipulate me but he thinks
just giving me some coffee is going to
somehow get me on his side right so
you'll feel manipulated by the gesture
they'll interpret the gesture in a way
that's consistent with what they already
think of you and that's really the
challenge now how do you get past
confirmation bias how do you get over
the primacy effect when let's say your
initial
rushon you gave someone wasn't that good
there are a couple ways to do it you can
kind of think of them as The Tortoise
and the hare ways of getting people to
update their impressions the tortoise
way because it takes a long time is
simply overwhelming them with an
abundance of really eye-catching
information that says I'm not who you
think I am right so it's not just
bringing them a cup of coffee the next
day it's going out of your way to be
nice day after day after day potentially
for a couple of months before that
person finally realizes there's there's
so much evidence that you're a nice
person that they say you know what that
what I thought of them originally that's
not true they're actually a really nice
person but it takes a ton of information
to do that and you really have to hang
in there for the long haul the the hare
method which is actually not that fast
it's really more of a faster tortoise
method is to find a way for you to work
with that person or have them kneed you
in some way because psychologists call
this creating an outcome dependency what
it means is that that person in order
for them to get what they want they have
to work with me and what naturally
happens when you create outcome
dependency between people is that they
become really interested in being
accurate about that other person right
because if I need you to get what I want
then I'm going to have to really pay
attention to who you are and be able to
predict you so people naturally take a
second look they don't just rely on that
initial impression they have they take
another look at you and they're more
willing to update and revise their
impression of you in order to be really
accurate this is why you find so often
people will say oh you know I thought
so-and-so was not that bright but then I
worked with him and I found out that he
was really smart well yeah working
together creates a real motivation for
you to be accurate about the other
person and that really opens up a door
for you to make a good second impression
if you've made a poor first one
you